[Applause]
it is for now at least the result julian
assange's supporters had wanted
[Applause]
[Music]
the wikileaks founder will not be
extradited to the us to face espionage
charges
for the publishing of classified
military and diplomatic documents in
2010 and 11.
the u.s claims the leaks broke the law
and endangered lives
and will appeal the ruling
[Applause]
outside the court assange's fiance
joined by the new editor-in-chief of
wikileaks welcomed the news
but said the fight isn't over let's not
forget
the indictment in the u.s has not been
dropped
we are extremely concerned that the u.s
government
has decided to appeal this decision
it continues to want to punish julian
and make him disappear into the deepest
darkest hole
of the u.s prison system there should be
a call out
and pressure on the u.s side
to drop the appeal to say enough is
enough
we've had enough of this we have plenty
to deal with
in this new year but not this
assange arrived at court from london's
belmarsh prison where he's been held
since april 2019.
his defense team has always insisted the
case was politically motivated
powered by u.s president donald trump's
administration
but one by one the judge rejected the
defense's claims
including concerns assange wouldn't get
a fair trial in the u.s
refusing extradition solely over fears
he could take his own life
if he ended up in a u.s maximum security
jail
the judge said he suffered from severe
depression and had been diagnosed with
autism
half a razor had been found in his cell
and he told medical staff about suicidal
thoughts
it was footage like this of us forces
killing civilians and journalists in
iraq in 2007
that drew intense hostility from the u.s
government
and after swedish prosecutors opened a
rape and sexual assault investigation
against him
he was arrested in london facing
imminent extradition
in 2012 he took refuge in london's
ecuadorian embassy and didn't leave it
for seven years
when ecuador finally let british police
in to haul assange
out the u.s allegations were finally
revealed
for publishing hundreds of thousands of
classified documents
a maximum 175 year sentence under the
espionage act
the prosecution has cast wikileaks as a
criminal
enterprise responsible for encouraging
its supporters to
hack into government computers and steal
sensitive information
but julian assange's supporters say that
he is a defender of freedom of speech
and the right for journalists to hold
the powerful
to account assange's lawyers will now
ask for his release on bail at a hearing
on wednesday
if granted he could be given a taste of
freedom within days
neve barker al jazeera london